the first time in human history we have
more overweight people walking the Earth
and underweight and by and large people
are being taken down by these kinds of
diseases of civilization diseases that
are that are essentially driven by being
undernourished and overfed our number
one recreational drug of choice is sugar
and it's true and so why are we sneaking
sugar into all these Foods because then
we'll want more of them so that's the
dirty secret of fructose that the
industry didn't want us to know about
now it's been called out added sugar is
Insidious today it's in everything it's
in sauces it's in coffee beverages right
we go to coffee chains for a cup of
coffee we end up drinking dessert
obesity diabetes metabolic syndrome
these are all risk factors for
Alzheimer's your average person today is
consuming 77 grams of added sugar every
single day it sets the stage for all the
bad things you don't want to get
Alzheimer's heart disease diabetes
obesity cancer we can demonize objects
people should not be drinking soft
drinks